ok am bauhaus in der ausbeutung hautnah
nur die nummern vergeben
hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einem neuen
video
ich bin zu hause mir ist langweilig und
da dachte ich probiere ich mal etwas aus
was ich mal wieder auf theater entdeckt
habt vielleicht nämlich erstmal meine
airports als nächstes ist ganz richtig
zu checken ob man lippenstift auch den
zähnen hat denn wie ihr euch vielleicht
schon gewundert habt habe ich heute
meine lippen sehr betont und dann
starten wir auch direkt mit dem video
denn ich bin sehr gespannt was dabei
rauskommt ich habe nämlich eine seite
gefunden über tik tok die einen
cocktails rauswirft man gibt auf dieser
seite alle seine zutaten ein die man zu
hause hat also den zitronensaft mango
scholle apfelsaft red bull wodka und der
wirft ein dann einen cocktail aus den
man mit diesen zutaten machen kann
endes meine damen und herren das sind da
dreht sie ballern dadurch können gerade
auf eis gelegt ist hoffe ich dass mir
auch diese cocktails neue inspiration
geben werden meinen horizont erweitern
und mich beim nächsten mal gewinnen
lassen
so beginnen mal auf die seite make me
cocktail sie sehen sie jetzt auf dieser
seite um einen stift ganz professionell
ok topspieler ingredients gucken wir mal
vielleicht finde ich ja schon was denn
habe ich wodka
ich glaube ich dass brandy whisky auch
nicht aber warum habe ich weit wein sei
da habe ich habe noch so wären
[Musik]
grenadinen lemon lime juice parkring
wörter tonic water und schoko cookies
cream habe ich auch david greene habe ja
auch marmelade pfeffer salz zucker du
warst du los angeles zac hab ich ich hab
sind sogar und rotkäppchen ist es also
mangos habe ich auch magazine cherrys
habe ich auch wo aps maracuja softdrinks
bitter lemon nein aber ich hab' ich will
das unbedingt drin haben
das pink lady wie zu hause das ist alles
oder
das ist alles okay leute jetzt kommt der
tollen moment auf den ich die ganze zeit
gewartet habt was für einen cocktails
kann ich aus diesem ganzen zeug was ich
hier rumliegen habe machen und mit der
kraft des mir verliehenen amtes wenn mit
gucken was für ein coupé betrinken könnt
cocktail
capri oscar cache oder chery cranberry
newsroom cherry red wine sparkling vodka
eu also welche mich auch sehr
interessiert ist
was sind das denn für cocktails absolut
wodka und champagner und das war's wohl
aber kann die uniform ist mal probieren
oder mir gefällt die farbe bacardi
superior um für diesen drink brauchen
wir ein sauberes glas tor nachdem wir
das glas nach gemacht haben nachgemacht
haben packen wesen gefriertruhe damit es
schön kalt ist und schon fühle ich mich
wieder linie keeper also ich habe zwar
keinen bacardi dunklen raum dafür habe
ich ja warum von bacardi o card spies
promised das gleiche oha musste man
jetzt die ganze die hässlichen dinge
hier sehen also erstmal brauchen wir
dort hier 4,5 cl rum 2 cl demonews und
ein ganz kleiner spritzer grenadinen
dann macht man einen deckel drauf ein
kühles glas sekt kalt aus und so schnell
haben wir uns in den cocktail mit der
super tollen seite mit cocktail gemacht
ostseite der rigali nach alkohol
[Musik]
ohu ein bisschen spies ich glaube dieser
ökonom ist so ein bisschen zu krass ja
er hat auf jeden fall ordentlich wumms
doch diese idee wäre ich niemals
gekommen bin ich ehrlich also davon
waren wir jetzt schon richtig begeistert
suchen wir uns einen zweiten drink der
rolle des islam in champaign ok dieser
drink klingt gar nicht mal so schlecht
beraten wir doppelten schusslärm andrews
also zitronensaft 1 schott zwei titel
und ein bisschen eis deckel drauf und
los geht's
[Musik]
und das in ein glas das dann mit
champagner oder wie in meinem fall
häppchen sekt aufgießen
sie habe fans sie aus und hier haben wir
unsere chips mit billigeren zutaten ja
doch den kann ich empfehlen der slacker
ein bisschen stark bis sehr stark den
geb ich kino so embers cosmoshop immer
wieder
ich habe die musste nicht und auch kein
foto aber was soll's okay let's go
mancher banker und denkt dran wenn er
vom spät ist ist er besonders gut war
dass angaben ein milliliter ja eine ist
das eine das ist eine einem milliliter
limettensaft zwei milliliter ich checke
das mit dem lied an ich glaube es
schlecht übersetzt die meile bestimmt
sehen wir haben ja noch über die null
vergessen haben wir über die null
vergessen
und 30 mango sieht lecker aus
dann brauchen wir natürlich eis so
richtig geschenkt
und hier haben wir kochten nummer 3 mps
kosmos leute ja man schmeckt ein paar
wien saft also ein richtig schöner
alkopop wo man den alkohol nicht mehr
raus schmeckt der schmeckt sauer sehr
fruchtig aber auch lecker auf zum
nächsten cocktail und da hier so
inspiriert bin noch einen viel besseren
koppel zu machen mit den zutaten die
hier haben denn ich bin die
ungeschlagene meisterin von drei
cocktails die ballern mache ich jetzt
den vanessa home alone mit timo becker
zockt dafür brauchen wir einen schuss
cranberrysaft einen schuss grenadinen
muss man große schuss ordentlich liebe
dich einen löffel zucker und das für mit
eis auf und dann müssen wir die scheiße
41 das tun wir uns da so aus und packen
wir sind unklar
das sieht schon richtig gut und das
alles wird getoppt mit martino kirschen
kommen und was lernen wir daraus die
besten ideen sitzen tief in uns drin
wenn es um alkohol geht ja ich hab's
doch gesagt hat er ist gut der ist
richtig gut kreis ja das war das video
ich hoffe mich hat's gefallen ich bin
jetzt diese woche im urlaub also ich
weiß nicht ob am mittwoch ein video
kommt wenn ja wenn nein dann freut euch
dass ich mal urlaub mache ich fahre nun
so hin ich will nur eine woche nicht
arbeiten kann ich das video gefallen und
dieser cocktail den letzten projekt bis
zum nächsten mal
das ist echt lecker lecker ein zusatz
muss ich noch sagen mir ist aufgefallen
dass ich gesagt habe die besten ideen
kommen von hier aber eigentlich habe ich
ja die ganzen ideen nur durch die
anderen cocktails bekommen also die
besten ideen kommen nicht wirklich
familie man lässt sich inspirieren und
dann hat man gute ideen